Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In the summer of 19 BC, the poet Publius Vergilius Maro, better known as Virgil, was travelling in Greece when he caught a fever. He took ship back to Italy, but died when he reached the port of Brindisi. He was just 50 years old. But that was not the end of Publius Vergilius Maro. More than a thousand years later, on the night before Good Friday 1300, another Italian poet found himself lost in a dark wood. And who should appear to guide him through the underworld but the ghost of Vergil? So begins Dante Alighieri's
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告干扰的音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公元前19年夏天，诗人普布利乌斯·韦吉利乌斯·马罗（更为人所知的名字是维吉尔）在希腊旅行时染上了高烧。他登船返回意大利，但在抵达布林迪西港时去世。他当时年仅50岁。但普布利乌斯·韦吉利乌斯·马罗的故事并没有就此结束。一千多年后，在1300年耶稣受难日前夕发现自己迷失在一片黑暗森林中。还有谁能指引他穿过幽冥界呢？但丁·阿利吉耶里的
The Divine Comedy, one of the absolute foundational texts of European and world literature. And Tom Holland, that's a really good example, isn't it, of the absolute foundational texts of European and world literature. And Tom Holland, that's a really good example, isn't it, of the imprint that the classical world, Greece and Rome, has left on our imagination. Do you think we're all kind of the children of Greece and Rome, really? Well, you know I have views on that. I do. Of course, we look back to Greece and Rome as a kind of a seedbed of ourselves. There are other influences on us as well that perhaps we might come on to.
《神曲》正是欧洲乃至世界文学的绝对基石之一。汤姆·霍兰，这真是一个很好的例子，不是吗？关于古典世界（即希腊和罗马）在我们的想象中留下的烙印的绝对基石。你觉得我们其实都是希腊和罗马的孩子吗？嗯，你知道我对这一点有看法。我有。当然，我们将希腊和罗马视为什么呢？视作我们自身的发源地。对我们产生影响的还有其他因素，也许我们接下来会谈到。
They're the ones we talk about, aren't they? They're the ones we talk about most. The history of how people have understood Greece and Rome since the kind of the end of the classical age is itself a massive theme of history. So, I mean, you cited Dante. I mean, that's a kind of classic example. Dante is the great classic of Italian literature, and Virgil has this absolutely starring role in it. And I remember something that probably the most famous classicist in the world, Mary Beard, said once, ages ago. it was it was long before she'd kind of
这些就是我们常常谈论的，不是吗？它们正是我们谈论得最多的那些。自从古典时代结束以来，人们如何理解希腊和罗马的历史本身就是一个宏大的历史主题。所以，我的意思是，你提到了但丁。我的意思是，这是一个典型的例子。但丁是意大利文学的伟大经典，而维吉尔在其中扮演了绝对的主角。我记得世界上最著名的古典学者玛丽·比尔德很久以前说过的一句话。那是很久以前，在她还没有成为
become a global superstar and she gave a lecture and she talked about virgil and she said that it was her opinion that pretty much since the moment virgil had laid down his pen to die there wasn't a day when someone hadn't read the aneid it's amazing um it is and so if we're going to talk about this this kind of this legacy the way that the legacy of greece and rome has kind of evolved and and and spread over the course of the centuries and the millennia who better to have on the show than the imperatrix the basilea herself mary beards and mary thank you so much for agreeing to come on and talk to us about this subject which is a subject that is actually
全球超级巨星之前，她曾做过一次演讲，谈到了维吉尔。她当时说，据她观察，几乎自从维吉尔放下笔离世的那一刻起，就没有哪一天会没人读《埃涅阿斯纪》。这太惊人了，嗯，确实如此。所以，如果我们打算讨论这种遗产——希腊和罗马的遗产在几个世纪和数千年里如何演变和传播——还有谁比“英帕拉特里克斯”（女皇）、“巴西利娅”（女王）本人玛丽·比尔德更适合来到节目中呢？玛丽，非常感谢你应邀前来，同我们讨论这个实际上
very much on you has been on your mind recently hasn't it because you've just published um a fantastic new book the 12 caesars which is about it's not actually about the 12 caesars themselves it's a bit about how they've been understood yeah that's right and the book is is saying, look, you know, every time we go to a stately home, you know, what do we see? We see a line-up of 12 Caesars, probably in rather vulgar porphyry or something, with a bit of gilding. And now even people like me tend to walk past, you know,
非常令你挂心、最近也一直占据你脑海的话题，不是吗？因为你刚刚出版了一本非常棒的新书《十二凯撒》。这本书其实不是关于十二凯撒本身的，而是关于后人如何理解他们的。是的，没错了。这本书的意思是，看吧，每次我们去参观庄园宅邸时，我们看到了什么？我们都会看到一排十二凯撒的雕像，可能由相当粗俗的斑岩之类制成，还带有一点镀金。现在，甚至像我这样的人路过时，也往往会
and think, yeah, 12 Caesars, on we go. And what I've done in the book, and it fits very much with, you know, the whole idea of why the ancient world still matters to us. You know, I started to ask why, what are these tyrants doing on our shelves? You know, why are we still so interested in Caesars? I mean, you're right to say, you know, I don't think Nero quite comes up to Virgil. But in terms of the visual world in which we live, we're still surrounded by these guys.
心想：好吧，又是十二凯撒，我们走吧。我在书中做的事情，非常符合古代世界对我们而言为何依然重要的整个理念。我开始追问：为什么这些暴君会出现在我们的书架上？为什么我们对凯撒仍然如此感兴趣？我的意思是，你说得对，我不认为尼禄能与维吉尔相提并论。但在我们生活的视觉世界中，我们依然被这些家伙环绕着。
We still use it. Even people who say, oh, I know nothing about the ancient world, which people often say. And they're always wrong because they always do. They're always wrong when they say that. But, you know, it's often the starting convo with me, you know, oh, I know nothing about the ancient world. People still pick up a newspaper, there's a cartoon of some politician who doesn't really have his mind on the job. You know, he's dressed up with a toga and a laurel wreath. And he's strumming a lyre and there's blazing fire in the background and we all know it's Nero fiddling while Rome burned we do we do and so Mary the critics have been raving about this book I'm going to quote I'm going to quote one particularly distinguished critic who has
我们至今仍在使用它。甚至那些自称“我对古代世界一无所知”的人——人们经常这么说。他们总是错的，因为他们实际上知道。他们这么说时总是错的。但是，你知道，这往往是我和别人谈话的开场白：“哦，我对古代世界一无所知。”人们随手拿起一份报纸，上面就会有一幅漫画，画着某个根本没把心思放在工作上的政客。你看，他穿着托加长袍，戴着月桂花环。他正弹着里拉琴，背景里烈火熊熊，我们都知道这就是尼禄在罗马大火时弹琴。确实如此。所以，玛丽，评论家们对这本书赞不绝口。我要引用一位特别杰出的评论家的话，他曾
written as this book triumphantly demonstrates there is no one on the face of the planet better qualified than Mary Beard to guide us through the great hall of mirrors labyrinthine and treacherous as it is that separates us from the 12 Caesars do you know who that distinguished critic was was it you it was yeah i am i'm coaching myself i know this is your first time in this podcast this is how it proceeds tom compliments himself a great length i'm complimenting but the reason i cite that is that i've actually rather yeah i am going to compliment myself here because I do like that idea of a great hall of mirrors, labyrinthine and treacherous. Because Mary, I mean, go on, tell me. I mean, that's OK. That's a good description. It is. You're a great wordsmith, Tom Holland, a great wordsmith.
写道：“正如这本书所无可辩驳地证明的那样，地球上没有人比玛丽·比尔德更有资格引导我们穿过那座虽然错综复杂、充满背叛、却宛如镜厅般的迷宫，正是它将我们与十二凯撒隔开。”你知道那位杰出的评论家是谁吗？是你吗？是我，对，没错，我在自我夸奖。我知道这是你第一次上这个播客，流程通常是这样的：汤姆滔滔不绝地自我赞美。我在自我赞美。但我之所以引用这段话，是因为我其实挺……对，我在这里就是要自我赞美，因为我很喜欢“错综复杂且充满背叛的巨大镜厅”这个概念。因为玛丽，我的意思是，说吧，告诉我。没关系，这是一个很好的描述。确实如此。你真是一个语言大师，汤姆·霍兰，一个语言大师。
Because the thing is that there is no one way to respond to it. And so obviously different ages have understood this in different ways so um yes so the roman empire collapses in the west and that's an important thing because obviously it continues in the east but in the west the legacy of classical literature and the memory of rome endures doesn't Yeah. And I think we now tend to think that, let's say, the rediscovery of classical antiquity, you know, was part and parcel not only of an intellectual enterprise in the early Renaissance, but it was also part and parcel of very much elite culture, dynastic power. We think of, you know, the big guys, the warlords of the late Middle Ages, you know, seeing themselves as Roman emperors.
因为问题在于，面对它并没有单一的方式。因此，显而易见，不同的时代以不同的方式理解了这一点——所以，嗯，是的，罗马帝国在西方崩溃了——这是一个重要的时刻，因为显然它在东方得以延续，但在西方，古典文学的遗产和罗马的记忆依然长存，不是吗？是的。而且我认为，我们现在倾向于认为，比方说，对古典古代的重新发现，不仅仅是早期文艺复兴时期一项知识事业的一部分，它也是精英文化和王朝权力不可分割的一部分。我们会想到，你知道，那些大人物——中世纪晚期的军阀们，把自己视为罗马皇帝。
And I think, you know, all that's true. But what I think is truer, both about images of emperors, but also about images of classical world in general, is that, and I suppose this is what you're talking about when you mention Hall of Mirrors, these figures have always been much more kind of fragile, ambivalent, difficult to pin down, curious. And one of the things that I'm wanting to do in the book you know is actually to say look everybody what did people in let's say 15th 16th century know think they knew they might have been wrong what do they think they knew about the 12 Caesars? Right. The first 12 Roman emperors, the most famous ones from Julius Caesar to Domitian, 12 rulers later. Well, they knew that all but one of them was rumoured to have had a not natural end. They read their Suetonius and other bits of classical literature and they knew that they were corrupt autocrats, etc., etc.
并且我认为，你知道，所有这些都是真的。但我认为，无论关于皇帝的形象还是关于广义上古典世界的形象，更真实的情况是——我猜这就是你提到“镜厅”时所要表达的意思——这些形象一直以来都更加脆弱、模棱两可、难以捉摸且充满奇趣。我在书中想要做的事情之一，你知道，其实就是对大家说：看吧，15、16世纪的人们，他们知道或自以为知道些什么？他们可能搞错了，但他们究竟自以为什么都知道关于十二凯撒的事情？没错。前十二位罗马皇帝，从尤利乌斯·凯撒到图密善，最著名的那些，经历了12位统治者之后。好吧，他们知道除了其中一位之外，其余所有人都据传没有得到自然的结局。他们阅读了苏维托尼乌斯和其他古典文学的片段，他们知道这些人是腐败的独裁者，诸如此类。
And yet they use them. They use the image of these rulers, which they pick up from ancient sculpture, but particularly ancient coins. And they decorate their private and public space with them. Now, we've sort of taken that for granted. You know, image of power, 12 Caesars. But actually, these figures are much more complicated than that. And one of the questions I wanted to ask, and it's become more relevant as my work on the book has gone on, is why did people want to see images of people they knew to be monsters in their homes, in their public spaces? And that leads you on to think, I think, a bit harder about,
然而他们依然使用这些形象。他们利用从古代雕塑、尤其是古代硬币中获取的这些统治者的形象，来装饰他们的私人和公共空间。现在，我们有点把这视为理所当然了。你知道，权力的象征，十二凯撒。但实际上，这些人物要远比这复杂得多。我想提出的问题之一——随着我创作本书的深入，这个问题变得越来越重要——是为什么人们会想在自己的家中、在公共空间里看到那些他们明知是怪物的人的形象？这自然会引导你更深入地思考：
so what are these images for? What are portraits of people from the past? You know, what are they doing? What are they for? How do they fit into, whether it's the 19th century, the 15th century or the 21st? Mary, let me ask you a slightly different but kind of broader question. At what point do you think those people are aware
那么，这些图像到底有什么用？过去之人的肖像画究竟是做什么用的？它们到底是干什么的？它们有什么用？无论是对于19世纪、15世纪还是21世纪，它们是如何融入其中的？玛丽，请允许我问你一个略有不同但更广泛的问题。你认为人们在哪个时间点，开始意识到
of Greece and Rome as belonging to a different age, a vanished age, and not part of a continuum, not part of their own world, if you know what I mean? I think it's very hard to know. I mean, the standard answer would be, I suppose, you know, Renaissance humanism, you know, burgeoning in the 15th century and a little before and later, in a sense, historicised the ancient world. It showed to the intellectuals of the West that the ancient world was a subject of study.
希腊和罗马属于一个不同的时代、一个已经消逝的时代，而不是某种延续的一部分，不是他们自己现实世界的一部分？如果你明白我的意思的话。我觉得这很难说。我的意思是，标准答案大概会是，你知道，文艺复兴时期的人文主义在15世纪及其前后蓬勃发展，在某种程度上将古代世界历史化了。它向西方知识分子表明，古代世界是一个研究对象。
It wasn't us. And up to a point, that's true. Do you think it's important that, I mean, there's a difference here between pagan and Christian emperors, isn't there? Well, I think that complicates things hugely because, you know, I'm rather carefully in what I've just said to Dominic, sticking, you know, taking the intellectual line and suggesting, hinting, which would be completely wrong, actually, hinting that the engagement with these figures was, you know figures was from people like me, only men in the Renaissance. You know, there was a kind of humanistic academic inquiry, which in a way put a barrier. It both opened up the ancient world, but it made it seem different. And I think you'd also have to say there's a parallel strand going on, which I think a lot of us now, we haven't forgotten, but doesn't come flooding in when you think about Roman emperors,
它和我们不一样。在某种程度上，这确实如此。你认为这其中很重要的一点是——我是说，异教皇帝和基督教皇帝之间存在着区别，不是吗？嗯，我认为这极大地使问题复杂化了，因为，你知道，我在对多米尼克刚才所说的话进行回应时相当谨慎，我坚持——采纳了知识分子的路线，并且暗示——而这其实完全是错误的——暗示与这些人物的接触，仅仅局限于像我这样的人、也就是文艺复兴时期的男性。你知道，当时有一种人文主义的学术探究，它在某种程度上设置了一道屏障。它既打开了古代世界的大门，又让它显得与众不同。我认为你还得说，当时还存在着一条平行的暗线——我想我们现在的许多人并没有忘记它，但当你想到罗马皇帝时，它并不会一下子涌上心头——
which is that the history of Christianity is actually embedded. The history of Christianity is embedded in the Roman Empire. And, you know, some of the most popular paintings that you get from the 16th century onwards, but you can find some examples earlier. The famous scene that we've now almost uniformly forgotten of the Emperor Augustus wondering if he was going to become a god and wondering if there was going to be anyone more powerful than him in the world and he consults a pagan prophetess a sybil and what does she do she points up in the sky and it's the very day that jesus is being born and augustus has a vision of mary and jesus in a cloud they do it rather you know sort know, they're not terribly good, most of these painters, at imagining that scene. But what we're being told is that those two histories come together. And also in Virgil, right? Because Virgil, I mean, one of the reasons why Virgil is Dante's guide is that it is believed that his poems, in a way, had foretold the coming of Christ.
那就是，基督教的历史实际上是深深嵌入其中的。基督教的历史根植于罗马帝国之中。而且，你知道，从16世纪开始（甚至你能找到更早的例子）一些最受欢迎的绘画中，有一个我们现在几乎已经完全遗忘了的著名场景：皇帝奥古斯都想知道自己是否会成为神，想知道世界上是否会有人比他更强大，于是他去咨询了一位异教女先知——西比拉。她做了什么？她指向天空，而那正是耶稣降生的日子，奥古斯都在云端看到了玛丽和耶稣的异象。画家们把这个场景画得——你知道——其实并不十分高明，大多数画家的想象力都算不上绝佳。但我们要被告知的是，这两段历史交织在了一起。在维吉尔的著作中也是如此，对吧？因为维吉尔——我的意思是，维吉尔之所以成为但丁向导的原因之一，就是人们曾相信他的诗作在某种程度上预言了基督的降临。
And therefore, he comes to become a kind of Christian necromancer. Yes. And so you get Augustus being the ruling emperor when Jesus was born. You get Nero as the great persecutor. I mean, you go to the great ceremonial doors on St. Peter's, which one of the few bits of new St. Peter's that were taken over from the venerable old St. Peter's. And who do you see first when you go into St. Peter's that way? You see Nero. Nero is sitting there and he is condemning Peter and Paul to death. And so Roman emperors are absolutely built in to the idea of the history of the church from its very beginning to the time when the Roman Empire itself, at least from the point of view of the dynastic leaders, when Constantine would
因此，他最终变成了一种基督教意义上的死灵法师。是的。于是你会发现，奥古斯都是耶稣诞生时的统治皇帝；而尼禄则是伟大的迫害。我的意思是，如果你去参观圣彼得大教堂那些伟大的礼仪铜门——那是宏伟的旧圣彼得大教堂所保留下来的为数不多的新圣彼得大教堂的部件之一。当你从那个方向进入圣彼得大教堂时，你第一个看到的是谁？你看到的是尼禄。尼禄正坐在那里，判处彼得和保罗死刑。因此，罗马皇帝从教会历史的最初诞生，一直到罗马帝国本身——至少从王朝统治者的角度来看，君士坦丁就是最典型的例子，他自己成为了一名基督徒，罗马帝国皈依基督教——这一整个历史过程都被绝对地嵌入到了教会的理念之中。所以，关于基督教的整个早期历史——我现在要说一些完全耸人听闻、甚至略有偏差的话，但这是一个很好的夸张——如果不理解其根植于罗马帝国的土壤中，基督教的整个早期历史是不可理解的。听上去这并不算充满争议，我觉得这相当合情合理。我认为这绝对合情合理。叙利亚语世界的某些部分可能会对其中的一些观点提出异议。我不知道有多少叙利亚语听众。我大概能蒙混过关，但你能感觉到我非常小心、在为自己留后路。我的意思是，玛丽，顺着这个主题——再次审视
be the classic example, becomes himself a Christian when the Roman Empire becomes Christian. So the whole of Christianity, I'm now going to say something completely outrageous and slightly wrong, but it's a good exaggeration. The whole of the early history of Christianity is incomprehensible without understanding its embeddedness in the Roman Empire. That doesn't sound controversial, that just sounds quite reasonable, I think. I think that's absolutely reasonable. There's some bits of the Syriac world which might contest some of this. I don't know how many Syriac listeners. I will probably get away with it, but you sense that i'm being very careful and covering my back i mean mary on on that theme of of um again looking at looking at
维吉尔、审视但丁、审视罗马皇帝被理解的方式——我的意思是，但丁认同凯撒的传统。他某种程度上是支持帝国对抗教皇的。所以，当他们深入到地狱的最底层并看到撒旦时，撒旦正在啃食犹大，但他也同样在啃食布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯。这两个人绝对是——我的意思是，因为谋杀尤利乌斯·凯撒，他们跻身于有史以来最恶劣的罪人行列。
virgil looking at dante looking at the way the roman emperors are understood i mean so dante is identifying with the tradition of the caesars he He's kind of, he's an enthusiast for the empire against the papacy. And so when they go down, you know, into the lowest pit of hell and they see Satan, he's gnawing on Judas, but he's also gnawing on Brutus and Cassius, who are absolutely, you know, I mean, they're up there with the worst people who ever lived for murdering Julius Caesar.
而且，你知道，所以这——我的意思是，我认为有趣的地方在于，这些有史以来因谋杀尤利乌斯·凯撒而成为最恶劣罪人的人。谋杀尤利乌斯·凯撒。所以这——我的意思是，我认为有趣、且我希望能在书中展现出来的是，这些等同关系以及这种嵌入性总是比看上去要复杂得多。它总是比看上去的要复杂。讲述早期教会历史的一种方式，当然是将异教皇帝视为残酷的迫害。但事情总有另一面，也总有另一种形式的互动。我的意思是，我最喜欢的器物之一——这可能有点夸张了——
And, you know, so it is, I mean, I think what's interesting with the worst people who ever lived for murdering Julius Caesar. Murdering Julius Caesar. And so it is, I mean, I think what's interesting, and it's what I hope I bring out in the book, is that these equivalences and this embeddedness is always more complicated. It's always more complicated than it looks. And one way of telling the history of the early church is, of course, to see pagan emperors as great persecutors. But there's always another side and there's always another kind of engagement. I mean, I think one of my favourite objects, it's a bit over the top,
是特兰西瓦尼亚一座大教堂里的特兰西瓦尼亚宗教圣杯，制作于16世纪或17世纪。太模糊了。这是一个圣餐杯。而在这个用来让信徒饮用基督之血、领受圣餐饼的圣餐杯上，镶嵌着什么呢？你看到了什么？他们上面镶嵌了一整排罗马硬币，其中就包括尼禄。所以你脑海中必须勾勒出的画面是：有人正在饮用圣餐酒，啜饮着圣餐酒。而当他们这么做时，他们面对的是谁？他们面对的是尼禄。因此，这些人物在某种程度上充当了一个世界，基督教的历史正是在这个世界中被理解的。有时这是为了将这些世界融合在一起——就像你的维吉尔与但丁的例子一样，
is a Transylvanian religious chalice from a cathedral in Transylvania, 16th century, 17th century. Fuzzy day. And it's a communion chalice. And what is set in this communion chalice, out of which the faithful are going to drink the blood of Christ and take the bread. What do you see? They've set in it a whole array of Roman coins, including Nero. So the kind of the image that you have to conjure up for yourself is somebody drinking the communion wine, sipping the communion wine. And as they do that, who are they brought face to face with? They're face to face with Nero. And so these figures are kind of operating as a world within which the history of Christianity is being understood. And sometimes it is to bring those worlds together, which you have with your Virgil and Dante example
以及许多这类例子中，奥古斯都总是不断出现在耶稣诞生的艺术语境中。所以你既在说这些历史是交织在一起的，又在说这些历史永远彼此对立。不过，玛丽，可以这样说吗：在西罗马帝国灭亡之后的整个历史中，罗马尤其被视为——
and with a lot of these, you know, Augustus is always cropping up in the context, in art of the birth of Jesus. So you've got, you're saying that these histories go together and you're also saying these histories are forever in opposition to one another. But it's fair to say, is it, Mary, that throughout the history subsequent to the fall of the Western Roman Empire, that Rome in particular has been seen,
我的意思是，希腊倒是不太明显——但罗马一直被视为与权力和某种威望同义，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个常量，不是吗，在后罗马时期的历史中？这确实是常量之一。当然，我们在这里确实可以把希腊先放在一边。我的意思是，对希腊的重新发现具有巨大的影响力，尤其是在19世纪。你可以追溯以下历史，比方说亚历山大大帝
I mean, I don't know so much with Greece, but Rome has been seen as synonymous with kind of power and a kind of prestige, right? I mean, that's a constant, isn't it, in post-Roman history? That's one of the constants. Certainly we can really forget Greece here. I mean, the rediscovery of Greece was hugely influential, particularly in the 19th century. And you can trace the history of, say, Alexander the Great
在这段时期的某些影响。但本质上，当我们思考对古代世界的想象以及古代世界对我们的冲击时，指的就是罗马。它关乎权力。它关乎超越凡俗的伟大。但它也关乎腐败。它关乎谋杀。它关乎走向歧途的王朝，它关乎迫害。这也是一个非常男性化的世界。所以，这种感觉实际上——如果我们审视中世纪、审视古典世界的遗产时，我们所谈论的其实就是罗马。我的意思是，希腊出现的程度——因此，特洛伊的故事、希腊神话——实际上都是通过罗马作为中介来传递的。
through some of this period. But essentially, when we're thinking about imagining the ancient world and thinking about how the ancient world impacts on us, then it's Rome. And it is about power. It's about larger than lifeness. But it's also about corruption. It's about murder. It's about dynasties going wrong uh it's about persecution um it's very male world too but so that that i mean that sense that actually what we're talking about in the middle ages if we're looking at the the legacy of the classical world is really rome i mean and and the the extent to which greece appears so the stories of the tro, the Greek myths, I mean, it's being mediated through Rome.
它们是通过罗马的中介来呈现的。另一个除了维吉尔和但丁之外你需要加入这个等式的人是，你会说，看吧，在这个时期（从中间世纪一直到巴洛克时期，我想），人们是从哪里知道我们所谓的希腊神话的？他们是从哪里知道这些的？好吧，他们主要通过奥维德了解它们。这些是希腊神话的罗马版本。而且我认为，他们总是带着一只眼睛斜视多米尼克所谈论的东西，实际上，既关注罗马权力，也关注罗马的想象力。他们围绕它提出各种不同的论点、辩论和讨论。我认为，如果说十二凯撒或其他任何罗马权力的形象，仅仅是对现代政治权力回顾古代时的一记极其简单粗暴的橡皮图章，它们就不会具有一半的锋芒，也不会具有一半的生命力。你知道，我们早就厌倦了。我们现在真的、真的会对它们感到厌倦。但正是因为它们总是能引发问题，而且总是比你想象的更难被轻易定性，
It's being mediated through Rome. And the other person that you'd add into the equation, along with Virgil and Dante, is you'll say, look, you know, where do people know what we call the Greek myths from at this period, anything from the Middle Ages to the Baroque period, I suppose. Where do they know those? Well, mostly they know them through Ovid. There are Roman versions of the Greek myth. And they're always kind of looking, I think, one eye over the shoulder at what Dominic's talking about, really Roman power as well as the Roman imagination. And they're making kind of different arguments and debates and discussions around it. I think that if the 12 Caesars, let's say, or any of these images of Roman power had been utterly, simply rubber stamps of modern political power looking back to antiquity, they wouldn't have had half so much edge. They wouldn't have had half so much longevity. You know, we'd have got bored. We'd have got really, really bored of them by now. But it's because they always raise questions and they're always harder to pin down than you think
它们才拥有如此持久的生命力。玛丽，我有两个问题。第一个是非常无聊、琐碎的后勤小问题：我们倾向于说“海格力斯”（Hercules）而不是“赫拉克勒斯”（Heracles），而莎士比亚指的是“朱庇特”（Jove）而不是“宙斯”（Zeus），仅仅是因为这一切都是通过罗马人过滤后传给我们的吗？是因为他们无法在没有罗马人作为中介的情况下接触到希腊神话吗？是的，主要就是这个原因。而且我认为，一旦你开始接触到——这比19世纪晚期要稍微早一点——一旦你看到一大群有自觉意识的希腊文化爱好者回过头来说：
that they've got such continuing momentum. Mary, I've got two questions. So one is a very boring, small housekeeping question. Is the reason that we think of Hercules rather than Heracles and Shakespeare refers to Jove rather than Zeus, is that just because we're getting all filtered through the Romans? That they don't have access to the Greek myths unmediated by the Romans? Yeah, it's mostly that. And I think that as soon as you get, and it would start a bit earlier than the late 19th century. But as soon as you get a load of self-conscious Hellenists looking back and saying,
“嘿，伙计们，你们需要——你们知道，还有别的地方可去。”那么，当然，我们就迎来了命名之争。你可以从——你知道，你可以看出，管赫拉克勒斯叫“赫拉克勒斯”的人是在告诉你：想想希腊吧。汤姆·霍兰。汤姆·霍兰就是那种人。
hey, guys, you need to, you know, there's somewhere else to go. Then, of course, we get the naming wars. And you can tell that in, you know, you can tell that someone who calls Heracles Heracles is telling you, think Greece. Tom Holland. Tom Holland is that person.
是的。好吧，我们有一个非常好的问题，比我刚才的问题好得多，来自我们的听众之一“SO3克劳塞维茨”。克劳塞维茨说——我认为这是一个极其迷人的问题——文艺复兴注定是希腊-罗马式的吗？
Yeah. Okay. So we've got a very good question, much better than my last question, from one of our listeners, SO3 Klausowitz. And Klausowitz says, and I think this is a fascinating question, was the Renaissance destined to be Greco-Roman?
所以他基本上是在问，是否存在一种反事实的假设：如果当年是埃及式、波斯式或其他更偏东方的风格，历史会怎样？还是说它注定永远是希腊-罗马式的？我想，由于罗马帝国对西欧留下的烙印，
So he says, basically, is there a counterfactual what if where it's Egyptian or Persian or whatever, sort of more Eastern, or was it always bound to be Greco-Roman? I suppose because of the imprints of the Roman Empire on Western Europe. I think that you could say it was almost bound to be. Because, you know, we're sitting in a continent and a landmass where we dig in the soil.
你可以说它几乎是注定如此的。因为，你知道，我们坐落在一个大陆和陆地上，我们在泥土里挖掘。
And what do we find? Well, if you're in Italy, we might find busts of Roman emperors. You know, you can be in Durham and we're finding coins with Roman emperors. You know, Shakespeare refers to the imprints of Roman figures on coins. But what lies beneath our feet is Roman, really. I mean, it's not actually Greco-Roman, it's Roman. What I think is, why that question I think is interesting is, of course, it's slightly challenging, the kind of assumption that comes from that,
我们能发现什么呢？好吧，如果你在意大利，我们可能会发现罗马皇帝的半身像。你知道，你身处达勒姆，也能挖到印有罗马皇帝头像的硬币。你知道，莎士比亚提到了硬币上罗马人物的印记。但实际上，我们脚下踩着的正是罗马的东西。我的意思是，它其实不是希腊-罗马式的，而是纯粹的罗马式的。我认为——为什么这个问题很有趣呢，当然是因为它稍微挑战了那种想当然的假设：
that the only thing worth studying in antiquity, the only people who've got any brains at all were the Romans and the Greeks. Now, in fact, we know that it's a much more complicated intellectual world than that, which certainly, for example, and there'd be many others, includes Egypt. And both the Greeks and the Romans knew that they had got boffins on board and they tell him how to reform the calendar. So you can't in kind of in my world when I'm teaching, I'm wanting to encourage students to look a little more critically at that kind of, you know Romano-Greek antiquity, I'll call it, and to see where it comes from and to see its relationships with the other cultures of the ancient Mediterranean. Mary, I mean, with the specifically on Egypt, of course, I mean, people were fascinated by Egypt in the Renaissance and they yearned to kind of crack what they thought was the hidden wisdom of the Egyptians. But they couldn't because they couldn't read the text.
即古代唯一值得研究的事物、唯一真正有点头脑的人只有罗马人和希腊人。然而事实上，我们知道这是一个比这复杂得多的知识世界，其中当然也包括埃及（除此之外还有许多其他文明），而希腊人和罗马人都知道他们曾向埃及人取经，埃及人教他们如何改革历法。所以你不能在——在我的世界里，当我教书时，我总是想鼓励学生更加批判性地看待那种“罗马-希腊古代”（我姑且这么称呼它），去探究它的来源，并观察它与古代地中海其他文化之间的关系。玛丽，我的意思是——专门谈到埃及，当然，在文艺复兴时期，人们对埃及着迷不已，他们渴望破译他们心目中埃及人的神秘智慧。但他们做不到，因为他们无法阅读那些文本。
That's right. I mean, the key to and of course, the key to the rediscovery of Greece is also the rediscovery of the Greek language and learning the Greek language. And I guess that we're calling this episode classic. So up till now, we've really been looking at, you know, the reception of Greece and Rome. But classics is also particularly about the languages, about Greek and Latin. And I wonder if we should perhaps go the way in which the idea of classics being the study of Greek and Latin and how that's kind of influenced the role. I mean, it has a kind of sense that this is a very elite thing to study and all that kind of stuff. And I know that you have strong views on that.
确实如此。我的意思是，通往——当然，重新发现希腊的关键，也是重新发现希腊语并学习希腊语的过程。我想我们将这一集称为“经典”（Classic）。所以到目前为止，我们实际上一直在探讨希腊和罗马的接受史。但“古典学”（Classics）也特别关乎语言，关乎希腊语和拉丁语。我想我们或许应该探讨一下，古典学作为对希腊语和拉丁语的研究这一理念，是如何影响其角色的。我的意思是，它给人一种印象，即这是一门非常精英化的学科，诸如此类。我知道你对此有强烈的看法。
So perhaps we could come to that after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
所以也许我们可以在休息之后再谈这个。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家加更节目并提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Ave, we are looking at classics, the way in which the civilisations of Greece and Rome have been interpreted, reinterpreted over the course of the centuries. And we have with us none other than Mary Beard, who is professor of classics at Cambridge and Mary this idea of classics the joining together of Greek and Latin as a fit subject of study at university I mean this is this has a very kind of lengthy tradition doesn't it I
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来，我们正在探讨古典学，探讨希腊和罗马文明在几个世纪中被诠释和重新诠释的方式。今天做客我们节目的是剑桥大学古典学教授玛丽·比尔德。玛丽，古典学的这个概念——将希腊语和拉丁语结合起来，作为大学里一项合适的学科来研究——我的意思是，这有着非常悠久的传统，不是吗？
mean in Europe but but it has it kind of takes on a particular contours in England. Yeah, it takes on particular contours in England. And it would be naïve to say that there's been no connection between class and classics, that the learning of Latin in particular, rather less Greek. Greek has always been a bit more kind of market recherche, you know. Bohemian, is it Greek? Slightly more bohemian, yes. And it's got all kinds of connections with some things that we don't much like. Like, you know, Athenian democracy was not terribly the flavour of the month in the early 19th century, for example. And so we're seeing it through Rome and we're seeing an elitism here.
在欧洲是这样，但它在英国呈现出了某种特别的轮廓。是的，它在英国呈现出了特定的轮廓。如果说阶级与古典学之间毫无联系，那就太天真了。尤其是学习拉丁语，希腊语则相对少一些——希腊语一直以来都更偏向于小众探索，你知道的。有些波希米亚风格，对吧？希腊语吗？稍微多了一点波希米亚风格，是的。而且它与某些我们并不是很喜欢的方面有着各种各样的联系。比如，你知道，雅典民主在19世纪初期并不是那么受人欢迎，举个例子。因此，我们是通过罗马的视角来看待它的，并且在这里看到了精英主义。
And also up to a point, we're seeing the acquisition of Latin as a gatekeeper to elite culture here. OK, so we have a question from Andrew here. What is it about studying the classics that seems to appeal to the elite? Well, I would say almost nothing. I mean, I think that one of the points about what, let's say, the English elite studied in the 18th and early 19th century was that they studied Latin and Greek. They studied language. And what did they spend most of their time doing? Well, they were translating Shakespeare into Latin. They were translating Milton into Latin. And part of the point of this,
而且在某种程度上，我们也看到掌握拉丁语成为了通往精英文化的守门人。好吧，所以安德鲁在这里提出了一个问题：研究古典学究竟有什么魅力，似乎特别吸引精英阶层？嗯，我会说几乎没有什么魅力。我的意思是，我认为，比方说18和19世纪英国精英所研究的内容之一，就是他们学习拉丁语和希腊语。他们学习的是语言。他们把大部分时间都花在做什么上呢？好吧，他们把莎士比亚翻译成拉丁语。他们把弥尔顿翻译成拉丁语。而这其中的部分意义在于，
and I think you can't really emphasise this too strongly, they weren't much. They were reading Virgil, but they weren't thinking about Virgil as a literary text. They were thinking about how they wrote like Virgil. And one of the kind of bizarre things and one of the things that made the learning of Latin so good as a gatekeeper to elite culture was it was also in many ways so pointless. So the pointlessness is the point. Pointlessness is the point. You were learning absolute fluency in a dead language. They were not. They were a bit, but they were not much, certainly not at school and not a lot at university. They were not thinking about the literary merit of the Aeneid. They weren't thinking much about, let's say, Roman philosophy.
我认为无论如何强调都不过分，他们并不是在阅读维吉尔，并把维吉尔当成一部文学文本来思考。他们思考的是如何像维吉尔那样写作。其中一件极其离奇的事情——也是让学习拉丁语如此适合充当精英文化守门人的原因之一——在于它在很多方面也是极其无意义的。所以，毫无意义本身就是意义所在。毫无意义就是意义所在。你是在学习流利掌握一门死去的语言。他们不是——他们多少懂一点，但并不多，特别是在学校里和大学里并不是很多。他们并不在乎《埃涅阿斯纪》的文学价值。他们也不怎么去思考罗马哲学，
They weren't reading Cicero in order to think about how you organized a state. The big, real focus of their learning was translating English into Latin. And we now think of classics as a subject. I'm happy to say it is very much now in the modern world as a subject which is about the Greeks and Romans. You have a you access it through language often, not always. But it's but it's about that kind of culture. I think if we'd gone back to the late 18th century, we wouldn't recognise what these people were doing. Mary, what's about this argument that's a bit... I know Tom's got a question about Thomas Hobbes, but I want to jump in before that.
他们阅读西塞罗并不是为了思考如何组织一个国家。他们学习的核心重点是将英语翻译成拉丁语。而我们现在将古典学视为一门学科。我很高兴地说，在现代社会中，它作为一门学科，很大程度上关乎希腊人和罗马人。你往往（但并非总是）通过语言去接触它。但它关乎那种文化。我想如果我们回到18世纪末，我们根本认不出这些人当时在做些什么。玛丽，关于这个有点……我知道汤姆有个关于托马斯·霍布斯的问题，但我相在前面插一句。
Oh God, I always pass on Thomas Hobbes questions. So my question is, there's a slightly, what seems seems to me a slightly crude way of thinking that people learn do classics because they want to be because of empire, because they want to purely because they want they would be imperialists. Is that right or is that wrong? I think it's half right. Most of these kind of stereotypes that we have about why and how the classics were studied in, let's say, 19th century, 18th century, they're always half true. And there is no doubt that some people who were avowed imperialists saw the Roman Empire as their lodestar, really, that Britain had taken on the mantle of ancient Rome and was, in a sense, replicating and doing better than the Romans. But I think it's more complicated than that. I mean, partly the relationship between the Roman Empire and the British Empire was always
哦天哪，我总是跳过托马斯·霍布斯的问题。所以我的问题是，有一种——在我看来——略显粗糙的思维方式，认为人们之所以研究古典学，是因为他们渴望帝国，纯粹是因为他们想要成为帝国主义者。这是对的还是错的？我认为这说对了一半。我们关于为什么以及如何在19世纪或18世纪研究古典学的那些刻板印象，总是只有一半是对的。毫无疑问，某些公开的帝国主义者确实将罗马帝国视为他们的北极星，认为英国已经接过了古罗马的衣钵，并且在某种程度上复制甚至超越了罗马人。但我认为事情要复杂得多。我的意思是，部分原因在于，罗马帝国与大英帝国之间的关系历来
a very fragile one. And I think you can see that if you go to the famous statue of Boudicca. Tom loves this. We've done a whole thing on this. Oh, brilliant. Well, you go to that statue and you look at what's written underneath. You know, here we've got, you know, a big rebel against Rome standing up for the native Brits against imperial oppression. And the poem that is the Cooper poem that's written by her underneath her, you know, says words to the effect of don't worry, Boudicca. Your descendants will rule more of the world than the Romans did. It's basically the message. I love that. So whose side are we on here?
是非常脆弱的。我想如果你去参观著名的布狄卡雕像，就能看出这一点。汤姆很喜欢这个。我们专门做过一期节目。哦，太棒了。好吧，你去那座雕像前，看看下面写的东西。你知道，这里我们有一个勇敢反抗罗马的叛徒，为了本土英国人挺身而出，对抗帝国的压迫。而写在她雕像底下的那首库珀的诗，大致表达了这样的意思：别担心，布狄卡。你的后代统治的世界将比罗马人还要广阔。这基本上就是它的信息。我太喜欢这个了。所以，我们到底站在哪一边呢？
And Mary also, I mean, it's not just in Britain, is it? Because in France, you know, they're using, in Algeria, the French see themselves as kind of the heirs of Rome, bringing civilization and baths and things to the desert wilds. But simultaneously, they're bunging up a statue of Vercingetorix to mark the defeat. And the Germans are doing the same with Arminius, who's defeated. That is absolutely right. So even with that broad equivalence between Rome and modern empires, there's always that. So, you know, who's coming out on top? Who's really like whom? I think also we tend to forget that Rome gave people a language
而且玛丽，我的意思是，这不仅限于英国，对吧？因为在法国，你知道，在阿尔及利亚，法国人将自己视为罗马的继承者，给荒凉的沙漠带来文明和澡堂。但与此同时，他们却竖起了一座韦尔金托里克斯的雕像来纪念失败。德国人对击败罗马的阿米尼乌斯也做了同样的事情。完全正确。因此，即使在罗马与现代帝国之间存在这种广泛的对等关系时，也总是存在着这样一面——所以，究竟谁会胜出？究竟谁才真正像谁？我也认为，我们往往会忘记罗马其实为人们提供了一种
for critiquing empire. Well, exactly. And that seems to be hugely important. You know, there were some of these, you know, some of these boys, they were boys at Oxford, nipping off to quotes, and I put all this in inverted commas,
批判帝国的语言。完全正确。这似乎极其重要。你知道，其中一些——其中一些年轻人，他们是在牛津大学的年轻人，抽空去——我把这一切都打上引号——
quotes rural India. Others were going up to work on the Manchester Guardian to say what an absolute pile of shite imperialism was. And they'd all learned it from the classics. But Mary, just before that, the reason I just wanted to mention Hobbes was that he famously, after the execution of Charles I, said people should not be reading Greek and Latin history, because it just encourages them to kill, you know, their rightful kings. You know, their tyrannicides and things. It's terrible behaviour. You know, it's got to be stamped out. And both the American revolutionaries and the French revolutionaries were absolutely steeped in the classical world. So it is also about, you know, it kind of underpins revolution, doesn't it?
“考察农村印度”。而另一些人则去《曼彻斯特卫报》工作，宣称帝国主义简直是一堆狗屎。而他们全都是从古典学中学到这些的。但是，玛丽，在那之前——我之所以想提霍布斯，是因为他在查理一世被处决后曾有一句名言：人们不应该阅读希腊和罗马的历史，因为这只会鼓动他们去杀死（你知道的）合法的君王。你知道，他们去搞弑君之类的事情。这是可怕的行为。你知道，必须予以取缔。无论是美国革命者还是法国革命者，都对古典世界浸淫极深。所以这也是关于——你知道——它在某种程度上是革命的基石，不是吗？
I have been banging on about this for more years than I like to think, you know, that there isn't inherent politics in the classical world. are classical examples, classical tropes, classical clichés to justify revolution as much as to justify oppression. And, you know, the classics has got a, you know, it's got a pretty kind of poor record when it comes to underpinning European dictatorship. You know, Mussolini's the start. Yeah, that's right. But it's also got a in my view others might disagree it's got a pretty fine record in asking people to critique imperial power to critique
我已经喋喋不休地谈论这个话题很多年了，时间长得我自己都不愿去想：古典世界本身并不存在某种固有的政治倾向。古典时期的典范、古典时期的修辞、古典时期的陈词滥调，既可以用来为革命辩护，也可以用来为压迫辩护。而且，你知道，当涉及到支撑欧洲独裁统治时，古典学的记录——你知道——其实相当糟糕。墨索里尼就是个开始。对，没错。但依我之见——其他人或许有不同看法——在要求人们批判帝国权力、批判
corruption I mean I don't see really how you can read even if you're not reading it for its history, how can you study the Roman historian Tacitus and not come away with a counter-cultural version about autocracy, one-man rule, and the corruption of empire? And indeed empire. Well, even beyond that, though, I mean, Tom and I were talking about this before we started the podcast, and I said to him that the two best-known,
腐败方面，它也有着相当出色的记录。我的意思是，我实在不明白，即使你不是为了历史而去读它，你怎么可能去研究罗马历史学家塔西陀，却没有从中得出一个反主流文化的版本——关于独裁、一人统治以及帝国的腐败？乃至帝国本身。好吧，不仅如此，不过，我的意思是，汤姆和我在录制播客之前就在谈论这个，我跟他说过，
popular, modern versions of the Roman Empire, so there are Claudius and the film Gladiator. And in both, there's a narrative device where one character wants to bring back the Republic. He says we're corrupt, we're autocratic, we're repressive. So even in our sort of modern retellings of Rome, that stuff is woven in. We can't ever, you can't ever tell Rome or you tell a very, very uninteresting story of Rome if you didn't keep that, that side, that other side on board. And I think, you know, look, for me, when did I first really see that Latin could speak for me?
人们最熟悉、最受欢迎的罗马帝国现代版本有两个，一个是《克劳斯》，另一个是电影《角斗士》。在这两部作品中，都有这样一个叙事装置：一个角色想要恢复共和国。他说我们已经腐败了、专制了、压制了。所以，甚至在我们对罗马的现代重述中，这些元素也深深编织在其中。我们永远无法——如果你不把这面、把那另一面考虑进去，你根本无法讲述罗马的故事，或者你只能讲述一个非常、非常无趣的罗马故事。而且我认为，你知道，看吧，对我来说，我什么时候真正第一次意识到拉丁语能为我发声？
It was when I read Tacitus and it was the biography, not his main histories of the early Roman Empire, but his biography of his father-in-law, Agricola. And I was a sort of disaffected lefty teenager. And I'd sort of fetched up learning Latin because they thought that's what brainy girls did. And we were reading Tacitus' biography of a curricular. And then I came across the bit where Tacitus puts into the mouth, admittedly, of a native Brit, though the native Brit never said it. He rallies the opposition to Rome by saying, what do the Romans do? They make a desert and call it peace. And that was when my eyes sort of opened because I thought there are people in the Roman world who were talking to me about me. You know, they're not just sitting there yomping across Gaul, you know,
那就是当我读到塔西陀的时候。那不是他关于早期罗马帝国的主要历史著作，而是他为岳父阿古利卡拉写的传记。那时我还是一个略显叛逆、左翼倾向的青少年。我阴差阳错地开始学拉丁语，因为他们觉得聪明女孩就该这么干。当时我们正在读塔西陀写的阿古利卡拉传记。然后我读到了这样一个片段：塔西陀借一个本土英国人之口——尽管这个本土英国人从未说过这话——他通过宣称“罗马人做了什么？他们制造了一片荒漠，却称之为和平”来号召对罗马的反抗。就在那一刻，我的双眼仿佛豁然开朗，因为我想，罗马世界里居然有人在谈论我。你知道，他们可不仅仅是坐在那里，在一片高卢大地上纵马驰骋。
on a kind of pledge of massacring the poor natives. They're thinking about what empire is. And, you know, actually, if you were to say, you know, has there ever been a better critique of empire than they make a desert and call it peace you know i i think taskers wins hands down at least on um succinctness and lucidity um well kind of on that a slight angle to that that we've got a question from murph man aka justin murphy who asks and i think it's a really interesting question, have classicists traditionally downplayed and do they still the cruelty and unfairness of the Roman world? And if so, why? I mean, that is quite an interesting question. Classicists inevitably are kind of passionate
带着一种屠杀贫困土著的承诺。他们正在思考什么是帝国。而且，你知道，实际上，如果你要说，你知道，是否曾有过比“他们制造了一片荒漠，却称之为和平”更好的对帝国的批判呢？你知道，我—我认为塔西陀在这方面绝对完胜，至少在简洁和明晰上是这样的。嗯，顺着这个话题，稍微引申一下，我们收到了墨夫·曼（Murph Man，又名贾斯廷·墨菲）的一个问题，他问了一个我觉得非常有趣的问题：古典学者过去是否淡化了、现在是否仍然在淡化罗马世界的残酷和不公？如果是的话，为什么？我的意思是，这是一个相当有趣的问题。古典学者不可避免地对
about the need to study the literature, the languages of these ancient peoples, does kind of emphasising the wonder of Virgil or Homer or whatever lead people to downplay the costs of what Greece and Rome meant for people? I mean, I hope I haven't. No, absolutely, you haven't. But I just wonder, the tradition, is this a problem with the tradition? I think there is a degree of a problem with tradition. You know, throughout my career, you know, I've been reading people like Moses Finlay or E.R. Dodds, you know, who are looking the classical world in the eye and always have done. And I think you can go back to the 19th century too,
研究这些古代人民的文学和语言有一种热情，强调维吉尔、荷马或诸如此类的伟大是否会导致人们淡化希腊和罗马对人民所造成的影响的代价？我的意思是，我希望我没有。不，当然，你没有。但我只是在想，这种传统，这真的是传统的问题吗？我认为这在某种程度上确实是传统的问题。你知道，在我的整个职业生涯中，你知道，我一直在阅读像摩西·芬利（Moses Finlay）或埃尔·多兹（E.R. Dodds）这样的人的书，你知道，他们直视古典世界，并且一直都是这样。我想你也可以追溯到19世纪，
and you can find writers doing the same. I think to some extent, there can be a fudge, as much in popular writing as in academic writing, from saying this culture is extremely interesting to saying this culture is admirable. And then tending to downplay things like the treatment of women, slavery and sexual violence, if you like. I mean, it's certainly the case that when I was at school and a bit when I was at university, we would read Ovid's Metamorphoses. Now, my young students now see Ovid's Metamorphoses, interesting as it is, as a work of literature, which is basically a handbook of rape. It's one rape after the next. And in some ways some ways that's true we never talked about it like that i mean we had that wonderful word rapture you know this was a rapture it wasn't a rape and that went hand in hand with a way of seeing the gods isn't it it's a way of seeing
你会发现作家们也在做同样的事情。我认为在某种程度上，可能存在一种敷衍，无论是在通俗写作还是在学术写作中，都是从“这种文化非常有趣”滑向“这种文化令人钦佩”。然后往往会淡化诸如对待女性、奴隶制和性暴力等方面的事情。我的意思是，当然，当我在学校的时候，以及在大学的一段时间里，我们会读奥维德的《变形记》。现在，我现在的年轻学生把奥维德的《变形记》——尽管它很有趣——看作是一部文学作品，这基本上就是一本强奸手册。这是一个接着一个的强奸。在某种程度上，在某些方面这确实是真的，我们从不那样讨论它。我的意思是，我们当时有那个美妙的词“狂喜（rapture）”，你知道，这是一场狂喜，而不是强奸。这与看待神灵的方式齐头并进，不是吗？这是一种看待
the gods you know and of course we can know, what price do you want to pay? I mean, it's kind of only an observation perhaps. Ask Semele. Ask Semele. You know, is there a downside to seeing the gods? Well, yes. Is there, you know, what is Ovid saying about what the costs are of that? But I think you could find that outside sexual violence.
神灵的方式，你知道，当然我们知道，你想付出什么代价？我的意思是，这可能只是一种观察。去问塞墨勒吧。去问塞墨勒。你知道，看待神灵有什么消极的一面吗？嗯，是的。有什么，你知道，奥维德对这其中的代价有什么看法？但我认为你在性暴力之外也能发现这一点。
But I think there was a tradition of seeing slavery as a bit in the model of country house service. It's upstairs, downstairs. Upstairs, downstairs. It's Downton Abbey. That's right. And the truth is that some of it probably was like that. And those are the bits we know about best. You know, the faithful slave of Cicero who gets freed and, you know, and remains a friend of the old master. Very nostalgic, euphemising version of slavery.
但我认为有一种传统，把奴隶制看作有点像乡村住宅的仆役模式。这就是楼上楼下。楼上楼下。这就是《唐顿庄园》。没错。事实是，其中有些部分可能确实如此。而这些正是我们最了解的部分。你知道西塞罗那个忠诚的奴隶，他获得解放后，你知道，依然是老主人的朋友。这是一个非常怀旧、被美化了的奴隶制版本。
Not entirely wrong in some cases. And what didn't we look at? We didn't look at agricultural slaves, slaves in factories, slaves in the mines. Yes, who would be castrated or blinded in an eye. I mean, how hideous. You know this story, Tom, but I'm going to tell it for your listeners. You know, there's the story of the Emperor Hadrian who gets mad at a slave and blinds him in one eye and then feels terribly remorseful and so says to the slave, please let me recompense you, let me buy a present, you know, and what would you like? And the slave says, my eye back, please. So Mary, let me ask you a question allied to that
在某些情况下并非完全错误。那么我们没有看什么呢？我们没有看农业奴隶、工厂奴隶、矿山奴隶。是的，他们会被阉割或弄瞎一只眼睛。我的意思是，多么可怕。你知道这个故事，汤姆，但我还是要讲给你的听众听。你知道，有个关于哈德里安皇帝的故事，他生了一个奴隶的气，弄瞎了他的一只眼，然后感到无比懊悔，于是对奴隶说：“请让我弥补你，让我买个礼物，你知道，你想要什么？”奴隶说：“请把我的眼睛还给我。”那么，玛丽，我想问你一个与之相关的问题，
about slavery and violence. The most famous, I mean, I know you've written about this, the most celebrated Roman monument probably in the world, the place that everybody goes to when they visit Rome, the place where children line up to pose with swords and to dress in the costumes. I believe Sandbrook Jr. is in that arena. He's going there for half term, isn't he?
关于奴隶制和暴力。最著名的——我的意思是，我知道你写过这个——可能是世界上最著名的罗马纪念碑，每个人去罗马都要去的地方，孩子们排着队摆姿势拿着宝剑、穿着戏服合影的地方。我相信小桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook Jr.）就在那个竞技场里。他半期假要去那里，对吧？
He is going there for half term and we've got it penciled in. So the Coliseum, gladiators, this is part of that, isn't it? Do you think, do you find, if you are driving past, do you find that distasteful and wrong? I don't warm to the idea of gladiatorial display um i hope it tells us a little bit about ourselves because when when sandbrook jr lines up and has his photograph taken with the dress-up gladiators um i hope i'm sure you point out to him, Dominic, that he's invested in that kind of violence and culture. I'm constantly interrogating violent practices in my episode.
他半期假要去那里，我们已经把它列入计划了。所以，罗马斗兽场、角斗士，这正是其中的一部分，对吧？你觉得，如果你开车路过，你会觉得这令人倒胃口且错误吗？我对角斗士表演不怎么感兴趣，嗯，我希望它能让我们稍微了解一下我们自己，因为当小桑德布鲁克排队并与装扮成角斗士的人合影时——我希望我确信你已经向他指出了，多米尼克，他是在为那种暴力和文化投资。我一直在我的节目中审视暴力行为。
And I think that the Romans are horrible. And one of the reasons we study them is because they are horrible. And, you know, they themselves wonder what they are doing, sitting down and, you down and supposedly enjoying the slaughter of human beings. We picture them as just a lustful crowd. And some of them aren't and some of them aren't. And some of them are both a lustful crowd and a questioning crowd about what's going on. But I think that we have to reflect a little bit on why we so like that site. So we find it tasteful, but we're so invested in that site.
而且我认为罗马人是可怕的。我们研究他们的原因之一就是因为他们很可怕。而且，你知道，他们自己也在想他们在做什么，坐下来，坐在那里，所谓的享受对人类的屠杀。我们把他们想象成只是一群好色之徒。但其中有些并不是，有些则不然。有些既是一群好色之徒，也是一群对正在发生的事情提出质疑的人。但我认为我们必须稍微反思一下，为什么我们如此喜欢那个地方。所以我们觉得它不雅，但我们却深深地投入到了那个地方。
Gladiator has its cake and eats it. Yes. And I suspect we have our cake and eat it and the Romans had their cake and eat it. I. And, you know, I suspect we have our cake and eat it and the Romans had their cake and eat it. I think that we also have to remember that it's there's been different versions of how we take that on board over the last few hundred years, because, you know, if we were in the middle of the 19th century and visited Rome, the Colosseum was then still basically a shrine to martyred Christians. And it was totally overgrown, extremely romantic.
《角斗士》这部电影两全其美。是的。我猜我们也是两全其美，罗马人也是两全其美。我。而且，你知道，我猜我们也是两全其美，罗马人也是两全其美。我认为我们还必须记住，在过去的几百年里，对于我们如何接受这一点，曾有过不同的版本，因为，你知道，如果我们身处19世纪中叶并参观罗马，斗兽场当时基本上仍然是殉道基督徒的神社。而且它完全被杂草覆盖，极其浪漫。
A great big cross. A great big cross. The cross is still there, but nobody notices it. And there was a little hermit in his hermitage, you know, in one side of the kind of overgrown garden. That's the classiest hermitage in the world, isn't it? Can you imagine a classiest hermitage? And if you said Colosseum then, it's about the persecution of the Christians. And of course, you go back to the reason why,
一个巨大的十字架。一个巨大的十字架。十字架还在那里，但没有人注意到它。还有一个小隐士住在他的隐修室里，你知道，在那个杂草丛生的花园的一侧。那是世界上最古典的隐修室，对吧？你能想象一个古典的隐修室吗？如果你当时说“斗兽场”，那就是关于迫害基督徒。当然，你追溯到原因，
you know, why was the Colosseum built in the first place? Well, there's two reasons for that. One is it was built by the new dynasty under Vespasian to obliterate part of the extravagant palace that the Emperor Nero had built. The Golden House. The Golden House. And the Colosseum is built on the site of Nero's ornamental lake. And it was it was a kind of quasi-democratic gesture. It was saying this used to be the private pleasure grounds
你知道，斗兽场最初为什么要建造？嗯，有两个原因。一个是由韦斯帕芗（Vespasian）领导的新王朝建造的，为了抹去皇帝尼禄（Nero）建造的奢侈宫殿的一部分。金宫。金宫。斗兽场是建在尼禄的观赏湖遗址上的。这是一种半民主的姿态。它是在说，这曾经是暴君的私人游乐场，
of a tyrant. And me, Vespasian, I am giving it back to public entertainment. It's like politicians playing football, isn't it? In a way, in a way. But just also remember the other kind of awkward side. How did Vespasian get the money to build this? Yes, how did he get it money to build this? Yes.
而我，韦斯帕芗，我把它还给公众娱乐。这就像政客们踢足球，对吧？某种程度上，某种程度上。但也要记住另一个尴尬的方面。韦斯帕芗是怎么弄到钱来造这个的？是的，他是怎么弄到钱造这个的？是的。
Well, very expensive piece of work. He got it because of his and his son's put down of the Jewish rebellion just before he took power in 69 and his destruction of the temple. Mary, just a thought about this kind of idea that perhaps we as a society generally perhaps don't engage with the brutality that underpins so much of, I guess, particularly Roman civilization. And I wonder if it's to do with the fact that most of us study it when we're children. It's a topic, you know, it's the childhood of Europe. Perhaps, therefore, it's appropriate to children. And, you know, the thing that I always have to struggle against is the influence of asterisks in which Julius Caesar conquers Gaul without killing a single person. And in which the Gauls are total sweeties.
嗯，这是一项非常昂贵的工程。他是通过他和他的儿子在公元69年他掌权之前镇压犹太起义以及对圣殿的破坏而获得的资金。玛丽，关于这种想法有一个小小的思考，即也许我们作为一个社会，普遍来说可能没有去面对支撑着如此之多的——我猜尤其是罗马文明的——残酷底色。我想知道这是否与这样一个事实有关：我们大多数人在还是孩子的时候就学习它。这是一个话题，你知道，这是欧洲的童年。也许，因此，它适合儿童。而且，你知道，我总是不得不与之抗争的一点是《阿斯特里克斯历险记》的影响，其中儒略·凯撒（Julius Caesar）征服了高卢，却没有杀死任何人。而且高卢人都是大好人。
Well, they're all sweeties, aren't they? In fact, we wouldn't much like living in ancient Gaul. No, an indomitable village, it'd be terrible. Absolutely terrible. But I think there is that. It is a kind of, you know, there's a certain infantilisation that we have of the ancient world, you know, a projection of, you know, the nuclear family
嗯，他们都是好人，不是吗？事实上，我们不会太喜欢生活在古代高卢。不，一个不可战胜的村庄，那会很糟糕。绝对糟糕。但我认为确实有那种情况。对古代世界存在着一种，你知道，某种程度上的幼稚化，你知道，对核心家庭的一种投射，
and we've got them all dressed up in their togas, you know, wife, faithful slave and husband and wife and two kids. But there's also, I think, a little bit of a sanctimonious self-righteousness about it. I mean, and I think that's the other side of our discussions of slavery, because you take students around slave quarters that you can identify in some Roman houses or Hadrian's great palace at Tivoli outside Rome. And they are terrible, dank, dingy workhouses, really. And even with clever students, you can often say to them, would we do that now? Oh, no, no, no, no, no, we wouldn't. You know, we don't have slaves.
我们让他们都穿上托加长袍，你知道，妻子、忠实的奴隶、丈夫和妻子以及两个孩子。但我也认为，其中有一点假惺惺的自以为是。我的意思是，我认为这是我们讨论奴隶制的另一面，因为你带着学生参观你在一些罗马住宅或罗马郊外哈德里安的伟大宏伟宫殿里能辨认出的奴隶区。它们真的很可怕、阴暗、昏暗、破旧。即使面对聪明的学生，你经常也可以对他们说：“我们现在还会这么做吗？”“哦，不，不，不，不，不，我们不会。”你知道，我们没有奴隶。
Well, it's convenient for us to imagine we don't have slaves. But, you know, think where your smartphone's made. Yeah. And in what conditions? And, you know, so I think that our relationship of investment in the ancient world is always combined with a sense of certain kind of self-righteousness about how much better we are. We are better. You know, I'm not going to take I'm not going to take a trip back to ancient Rome if you paid me a very, you know, you know, it's not like. Not even if you were going to be an empress. I was going to know. So you'd me a very you know you know it's not kind of like I was a celebrity get me out of ancient Rome you know um great show that would be um but we have to see that there's there's a complexity here in our engagement and uh we've we tend to think about these things in very binary terms.
嗯，我们假装自己没有奴隶，这倒挺方便的。但是，你知道，想想你的智能手机是在哪里制造的。是的。是在什么条件下？而且，你知道，所以我认为我们在古代世界的投资关系总是伴随着一种某种程度的自以为是，觉得自己好得多。我们更好了。你知道，如果要我回到古代罗马，你花大价钱请我，你知道，你知道，这可不像……哪怕你是要做女皇。我本来要知道的。所以你会——我——一个非常，你知道，你知道，这不就像——我是个名人，快把我从古罗马弄出去，你知道，嗯，那会是个很棒的节目。嗯，但我们必须看到，这里有一种复杂性，在我们对它的参与中，而且——呃——我们倾向于用非常二元的术语来思考这些事情。
Well, Mary, this raises some really interesting questions about the future of classics, which is, of course, so... I mean, a lot of listeners won't know this, but in America, in academic circles, I mean, really, I think specifically in America, it is intensely controversial. there's an assistant professor at Princeton called Danel Padilla Peralta, who has written and spoken at length about basically dismantling classics as a subject, because he believes that classics is a kind of bull book of white supremacy, Eurocentrism, all of these terrible things. What's your take on all that? Well, I think I should say that, particularly in the case of Danel, he's really smart and what he writes on Roman history is extremely good. I think that there's a baby in bathwater problem here. And it does play out differently in the context of post-slavery America. It does play out differently. But I think that, you know, anybody who studies classics
嗯，玛丽，这引发了一些关于古典学未来的非常有趣的问题，这当然是如此……我的意思是，很多听众不知道这一点，但在美国的学术界，我的意思是，真的，我认为特别是在美国，它是极其具有争议的。普林斯顿大学有一位名叫丹尼尔·帕迪拉·佩拉尔塔（Danel Padilla Peralta）的助理教授，他写过并长篇大论地谈论基本上要拆解古典学这门学科，因为他认为古典学某种程度上是白人至上主义、欧洲中心主义以及所有这些可怕事情的堡垒。你对这一切有什么看法？嗯，我认为我应该说，特别是在丹尼尔的案子里，他非常聪明，他关于罗马历史的文章写得非常好。我认为这里存在一个把婴儿和洗澡水一起倒掉的问题。在后奴隶制美国的背景下，它的表现确实有所不同。它确实表现不同。但我认为，你知道，任何研究古典学
and tries to deny that it has been used to legitimate some of the, you know, most horrible political movements that we've got, you know, would just not be looking history in the face. I think what the
并试图否认它曾被用来为我们所经历的一些最可怕的政治运动合法化的人，你知道，简直就是不敢正视历史。我认为那些美国古典学最激进的批评者有时往往会忘记的是，首先，这还有另一面。你知道，正如我们所提到的，你知道，有革命的那一面。去看看革命时期的建筑。我们认为建筑和古典学就是查尔斯王子喜欢圆柱。但看看布勒（Boulay）和18、19世纪法国的那些人，他们如何使用古典形式来重构建筑本质。那些把古典学当作白人至上主义堡垒、各种极右翼事业的人，通常都大错特错了。他们是非常糟糕的古典学者。
most fervent of those critics of classics in the States tend to sometimes forget is that, first of all, there is another side to it. You know, as we've mentioned, you know, there's the revolutionary side. Go and look at revolutionary architecture. We think of architecture and classics as being Prince Charles liking columns. But look at Boulay and people like that in the French 18th, 19th century using classical forms to reconfigure the very nature of what architecture is. the people who use classics as a bullock for white supremacy, you name it, far-right causes, usually they've got it terribly wrong. They're very bad classicists.
（注：原文重复或错漏已在上文合并调整，此处按原文顺序翻译：64-65段落交织，调整为连贯译文）——我认为可能我们可以花更多时间耐心地解释为什么斯巴达人，例如，并不完全值得赞赏，也不是现代国家的良好模范。我们刚才已经讨论过古典学的研究到哪里结束。不仅存在以希腊罗马为中心的倾向，而且非常集中在意大利和现在现代希腊的领土上。我认为还有很多工作要做，那就是说，看吧，非洲大陆的部分地区，是罗马帝国至关重要的部分。而古典学者有时自己也给人一种印象，认为这是一个白人的学科。现在，它不是，而且很久以来都不是了。但我想我们在决定把它付之一炬之前，应该先大声宣扬这一点。古典学无论如何都正处于濒危状态，这难道没有危险吗？我的意思是，古典学总是处于四面楚歌的境地，不是吗？
I think that possibly we could spend more of our time just patiently explaining why the Spartans, for example, are not entirely admirable and represent a good model for a modern state. We've talked a bit already about where the study of classics ends. And there has been a very, not just Greco-Roman centeredness, it's been very centered on Italy and what is now modern Greece. And I think there's a lot to be done in saying, look, parts of the African continent, crucially important parts of the Roman Empire. And classicists have sometimes themselves given the impression that it was a white man's subject. Now, it isn't and hasn't been for a long time. But I think we ought to shout a bit about that before we decide to burn it all down. And isn't there a danger as well that classics is just endangered anyway? I mean, classics is always a bit embattled, isn't it?
我想，或许我们可以花更多时间，耐心地解释为什么比如斯巴达人并非完全值得钦佩，也不是现代国家的良好模范。我们之前已经讨论过古典学研究的局限在哪里。不仅存在非常严重的希腊-罗马中心主义，而且还非常集中于意大利和现在的现代希腊。我认为还有很多工作要做，比如指出非洲大陆的部分地区是罗马帝国至关重要的部分。古典学者有时自己也给人一种印象，即这是一门白人的学科。然而现在它不是，而且很长一段时间都不是了。但我认为，在我们决定彻底推翻它之前，我们应该为此大声疾呼。而且，古典学本身不就已经面临危机了吗？我的意思是，古典学总是处于腹背受敌的境地，不是吗？
Well, I think it's been embattled since about the fourth century AD, probably. You know, I mean, there is something about classics which embedded in the subject is the idea that people before us did it better. Right. That's interesting. You know, and so there's a venerable classical organisation in this country, the Classical Association, founded in the early years of the 20th century. Why did they fight it? Because they thought that classics was going down the tubes. They wanted to have a society that would preserve classics. Now, we look back to the early years of the 20th century as a moment when classics was, you know, you could see it everywhere.
嗯，我认为它大概从公元4世纪左右开始就四面楚歌了，可能吧。你知道，我的意思是，古典学有一种特质，那就是这门学科本身就根植着这样一种观念：我们之前的人做得更好。没错。这很有趣。你知道，在这个国家有一个历史悠久的古典学组织——古典学协会（Classical Association），成立于20世纪初。他们为什么要为之奋斗？因为他们认为古典学正在走下坡路。他们想要建立一个能够保护古典学的协会。现在，我们回首20世纪初的那段时期，那时的古典学，你知道，随处可见。
Their perception was people aren't doing as well as they used to be. We need this. You know, there are people kind of pleased because I think, you know, although one way of representing classics is that it's an awfully self-confident, elitist discipline, which kind of involves not much more than quoting bits of Homer at random. You know, it's also a discipline that as long as I've been involved and for decades earlier has been concerned about itself, you know, wondered what it was for, how it should fit into a modern curriculum, etc, etc. You know, classicists are, you know, they're quite sort of heart-searching. They're not... Well, Mary, there's a question from Mark Woodhouse. If we stopped studying classics tomorrow, what would we lose? I mean, that's it. That's it. Yeah. Well, that's for you. I actually wrote an exam question almost exactly like that about 20 years ago. If classics goes, what else goes? It was my exam question. I don't think many people answered it, I have to say. But I think that we've already touched on that. You know, I'm not in any way an advocate of, you know, every 11 year old being put through compulsory Latin, you know, for whatever reason.
他们的看法是，人们做得不如以前好了。我们需要这个。你知道，有些人挺高兴的，因为我认为，尽管表现古典学的一种方式是它是一门非常自信、精英主义的学科，其中包含的不过是随口引用几句荷马史诗。你知道，这也是一门只要我参与其中以及在此之前几十年里一直关心自身的学科，你知道，它想知道它的用途是什么，它应该如何融入现代课程等等，等等。你知道，古典学者，你知道，他们会进行相当程度的心灵探索。他们不是……嗯，玛丽，马克·伍德豪斯（Mark Woodhouse）有一个问题。如果我们明天停止研究古典学，我们会失去什么？我的意思是，就是这样。就是这样。是的。嗯，那是给你的。大约20年前，我实际上写过一道几乎一模一样考试题。如果古典学消失了，还有什么会消失？这就是我的考题。我得说，没几个人回答出来。但我认为我们已经触及了这一点。你知道，我绝对不是那种主张让每个11岁的孩子出于某种原因都必修拉丁语的人。
You know, I am an advocate of people getting the opportunity to study Latin and that to be encouraged. But in a sense, I think we've we've already hinted at what would go. I mean, if you're going to read Dante, how do you read Dante if nobody in your culture, and happily, culture is a kind of sharing enterprise, so we don't need absolutely everybody to have read Virgil, but how is Dante going to make sense to us without Virgil still being on our cultural horizon. You know, you look at the Coen brothers, O Brother Where Art Thou, which is based on the Odyssey. Is that kind of movie possible without that sense that Homer is still part of our world? I don't think that you, you know, as I say say classicists can sometimes come over
你知道，我主张人们获得学习拉丁语的机会并受到鼓励。但从某种意义上说，我认为我们已经暗示了会失去什么。我的意思是，如果你要读但丁，如果你们文化中没有人——而且幸运的是，文化是一种共享的事业，所以我们不需要绝对每个人都读过维吉尔——但如果维吉尔不在我们的文化地平线上，但丁对我们来说怎么能说得通呢？你知道，你看科恩兄弟的《逃狱三王》（O Brother, Where Art Thou?），这部电影是根据《奥德赛》改编的。如果没有荷马仍然是我们世界一部分的那种感觉，那种电影可能拍得出来吗？我不认为你，你知道，正如我所说，古典学者有时可能会表现得
a bit heavy and a bit strong but my claim would be and this is one of the reasons of course that i wrote the book is that a visit to a art gallery a major western art gallery is actually impoverished if you don't know what the painters are painting. So to turn that slightly on its head. So if classics went, if there was no opportunity to study ancient Greece and Rome, I reckon that there would still be people who would want to do it desperately. And one of the reasons for that is I remember an editor years ago when I was kind of debating what to write a subject. And he said that, you know, the top three topics that sell to the general public, obviously, Second World War comes in absolutely miles ahead. Then Tudors and then the Romans. Not the Greeks, not the Egyptians.
有点沉重和强硬，但我的主张是——这也是我写这本书的原因之一——如果你不去了解画家们在画什么，去艺术馆、去主要的西方艺术馆参观，其实会变得索然无味。所以把这个稍微颠倒一下。因此，如果古典学消失了，如果没有机会研究古希腊和罗马，我估计仍然会有人拼命想去研究它。其中一个原因我记得多年前当我正在争论该写什么主题时，一个编辑对我说，他说，你知道，最畅销的前三大通俗历史主题，显然第二次世界大战遥遥领先，然后是都铎王朝，然后是罗马人。不是希腊人，不是埃及人。
It was always, but the Romans in particular have that glamour. And I wonder that a lot of the hesitancy that kind of shadows maybe the study of classics is in part a fear of that glamour, that it's seen as a kind of almost... it's dangerous perhaps. It's hard to control because it is alien to us. Yeah, that's that's why it's exciting. You know, it's sheer alienness, while also the sense that it remains part of our world is what gives it. Which is what Gladiator gave, wasn't it? Which is what Gladiator gave. But I also think that there is huge popular interest.
总是这样，但罗马人尤其有一种魅力。我想，笼罩着古典学研究的许多犹豫，部分原因是对这种魅力的恐惧，它被视为几乎是……也许是危险的。它很难控制，因为它对我们来说是异质的。是的，这就是为什么它令人兴奋。你知道，它的纯粹异质性，同时又感觉到它仍然是我们世界的一部分，这正是它所赋予的魅力。这也是《角斗士》所给予的，不是吗？这也是《角斗士》所给予的。但我也认为有巨大的大众兴趣。
You know, you only have to look at what plays sell out in the West End. But I also think that there is huge popular interest. You only have to look at what plays sell out in the West End. Now we can go back to the theatre and the ancient Greek tragedy is still a blockbuster. It's still putting bums on seats. that why that popular enthusiasm can be sustained is because there are people doing some hard, possibly not very glamorous, academic work on those texts, which keep them on the intellectual and contemporary horizon. I mean, I think people often say to me, but we don't need people like you because everything's been translated. And I said, well, look, if you think, go back to Gilbert Murray's translations of Greek tragedy in, and you wouldn't have a run of more than a week if you tried to put it on. Because actually what Murray was doing is what we all do,
你知道，你只需要看看西区（West End）有哪些戏剧票卖光了就知道了。但我也认为有巨大的大众兴趣。你只需要看看西区有哪些戏剧票卖光了就知道了。现在我们可以回到剧院，古希腊悲剧仍然是一个轰动之作。它依然座无虚席。为什么这种大众热情能够持续下去，是因为有些人正在对这些文本进行艰苦的、可能并不那么光鲜的学术研究，正是这些研究让它们保持在知识和当代的视野中。我的意思是，我认为人们经常对我说，但我们不需要像你这样的人，因为一切都已经被翻译了。我说，好吧，听着，如果你这么认为，回想一下吉尔伯特·默里（Gilbert Murray）在某某时期翻译的希腊悲剧，如果你试图把它搬上舞台，你的演出绝不会超过一个星期。因为实际上默里在做的事情正是我们大家都在做的事，
which is mediating the ancient world to our own concerns. And of course, making our own concerns seem different in the light of ancient concerns. But you sure can't do it with the rhyming couplets of Gilbert Murray in 2021. And so keep on supporting the doing of academic classics as well as gladiator. You are, as ever, the most eloquent defender of your of your discipline uh it's been it's been
那就是将古代世界转译并传达给我们自己的关切。当然，也通过古代的关切让我们的关切显得与众不同。但你肯定不能用吉尔伯特·默里在2021年的押韵对句来做到这一点。所以，请继续支持学术古典学的研究，就像支持《角斗士》一样。你一如既往是你所属学科最雄辩的捍卫者。呃，很高兴
wonderful to have you on but we have one last question tom dominic does it's dominic here who is massively lowering the tone let's just know that we like to end with the really big historiographical kind of what they call the meta questions so we've had a question an excellent question i know you've responded to this already so so I know your game. It's from Carlos D. And this is the question I think that everybody wants to know the answer. If Alexander the Great fought Julius Caesar, who would win? It's a brilliant question, isn't it?
你能来做客，但我们还有一个最后的问题，汤姆。多米尼克，是多米尼克，他大大拉低了对话的格调，让我们知道我们喜欢以真正的宏大史观、所谓元问题来结束。所以我们有一个问题，一个极我知道你已经回答过这个问题了，所以我知道你的套路。这是卡洛斯·D（Carlos D.）提问的。这也是我认为每个人都想知道答案的问题：如果亚历山大大帝与儒略·凯撒对决，谁会赢？这是一个绝妙的问题，不是吗？
All I can tell you... With their armies, do we think, or kind of man on man? Yeah, they've got to have armies. It's not man to man. One thing I can tell you, I'm not very good. You're so much better at military history than me Dominic and I'm sure that you could give a... Dominic hates military history. Well, if he hates military history, God knows who
我能告诉你的是……带着他们的军队，我们觉得，还是单挑？对，他们得有军队。这不是单挑。我能告诉你的一件事是，我不太擅长。你比我擅长军事史得多，多米尼克，我确信你可以给出……多米尼克讨厌军事史。好吧，如果他讨厌军事史，天知道谁会
loves it. But what I would say is do you know it's really interesting because the Greeks and Romans thought that? Yeah, it's like Plutarch's lives, isn't it? When Plutarch writes his lives, the great Greeks and the great Romans, and he puts them into pairs, he pairs Julius Caesar with Alexander the Great. So you've got a kind of double-headed biography.
喜欢它。但我要说的是，你知道这真的很有趣，因为希腊人和罗马人也这么想。是的，这就像普鲁塔克的《名人传》，不是吗？当普鲁塔克写他的《名人传》时，伟大的希腊人和伟大的罗马人，他把他们配成对，他把儒略·凯撒和亚历山大大帝配在一起。所以你得到了某种双头传记。
And part of the issue is, OK, so which of them would win, guys? Well, which of them is it? You're the professor of classics. We want to know. Everyone's hanging. But it's very hard because neither of them last very long, really. So if you were to say Augustus, is it Alexander the Great or Augustus? That's very evasive.
部分问题在于，好吧，那他们俩谁会赢呢，伙计们？嗯，他们到底是哪一个？你是古典学教授。我们想知道。所有人都悬着心。但这是很难的，因为他们俩都没有活太久。所以如果你要说奥古斯都，是亚历山大大帝还是奥古斯都？这太逃避问题了。
Then I would go for Augustus because he was kind of unbatterable. I'm going to take the Roman part and say they were both absolutely horrific massacres of innocent human beings, but probably Julius Caesar has the edge. See, I don't want to – it's foolish to disagree with the professor of classics, but I think Alexander would win because he had a track i said this to tom beforehand he had a track record of fighting bigger against bigger odds the big superpower of the day persia julius caesar just fighting a load of ghouls i agreed with you but obviously this is a debate that will run and run and run what do you the listener think let us know Alexander was a terrible drunk
那我会选奥古斯都，因为他基本上是不可动摇的。我要站在罗马这一边，并说他们两个对无辜人类的屠杀都绝对是可怕的，但可能儒略·凯撒略占上风。看，我不想——与古典学教授意见不一是很愚蠢的，但我认为亚历山大会赢，因为他有记录——我在事前对汤姆说过这个——他有面对更大劣势进行战斗的历史记录。当时的大超级大国波斯，而儒略·凯撒只是在打一堆高卢人。我同意你的看法，但显然这是一个将不断争论下去的辩论。听众朋友们，你们怎么看？让我们知道。亚历山大是个可怕的酒鬼，
that was his Achilles heel well you're just listening to the Roman propaganda here aren't you I think this is the perfect note on which to end Mary thanks so much and thank you everyone for listening and we will see you again soon bye bye thanks very much bye bye everybody thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是他的阿喀琉斯之踵。好吧，你在这里只是在听罗马的宣传，不是吗？我认为这是结束节目的完美音符。玛丽，非常感谢，也谢谢大家的收听，我们很快再见。拜拜。非常感谢，大家再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前访问、无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，那是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。